i've had some weird jobs in my life
i've had some weird jobs in my life man
and by the way i don't say when i say
weird and you guys know me you you know
i like weird [ __ ]
i like weird [ __ ] and when i say weird i
don't say weird in a negative way weird
to me is interesting normal to me is
boring
like weird is the sauce man we we all
need to be in the sauce you know
and so
i had a job once when i was a younger
dude
enter
entertaining at children's parties bad
idea on his part uh
and so this was so crazy at the time
uh my only means of transportation was a
moped
and the muffler broke on the moped
so it sounded like this
it sounded like a harley so you'd hear a
lego
let's see what's coming down the street
it was me on a moped like hey
right
so at the time
i was working entertaining at children's
parties and the dude who owned the
company
his rule was you're not allowed to show
up in civilian clothes you got to show
up in character the kids have to see you
in character
well everybody else had a car
and i had a [ __ ] moped you know
and he would assign he assigned
everybody three characters he would look
at you and assign the characters and he
assigned me clown which was fine
a teenage mutant ninja turtle
the last one bothered me a little bit i
was peter pan
and by the way on a side note if you if
you ever go to a children's party
dressed as a teenage mutant ninja turtle
you will get kicked in the nuts
repeatedly you're gonna hear because you
can't see with that big [ __ ] head on
right and all you hear is yeah and then
a second later oh like that hit
they all think they're [ __ ] ninjas
but one day i'm dressed like peter pan
and i'm on the moped
and i'm feeling like a lego guy
and i'm on a stoplight
and this police officer pulled up
he rolled down the window and he looked
at me and he goes hey
i said yes sir
and he said i was going to give you a
ticket for no helmet but
looks like your life's going bad enough
as it is
you [ __ ] drove away and i was like
yeah you're not wrong i mean what the
[ __ ]
so one time i'm at this party right and
the guy called me he goes hey you're
going to the clown lady's house i go
what the [ __ ] does that mean
and he goes she only orders this is her
first fifth clown party this year
i go oh all kid parties she goes no this
is the first this is the first kid party
and i was like what
so i show up
and i'm in my clown office
and this woman right away makes a
beeline for me and she
grazes my ass with her hand
not back front
and uh i'm like oh okay
you know i'm i'm 22.
and uh
she said to me looks right at me she
goes hey and i said yeah she goes
if i squeeze that flower will something
come out
i was like a little bit just came out
right now
i'm 22. it doesn't take much for
anything to come out you know
so it turns out she had a bit of a clown
fetish
all party she's walking by me grazing my
ass grazing my nuts making little
comments
and i'm like
all i kept thinking myself is
am i gonna [ __ ] a grown up dressed like
a clown
because at 22 i still uh
they were grown-ups to me i was not you
know i'm like i'm a [ __ ] grown-up
dressed like a clown you know
and so
she goes come find me at the party so i
can pay you and i was like yeah yeah
so
in the party i'm ready to get paid she
was following me upstairs
and i said okay
so i'm following her upstairs and she
was wearing a skirt and she lifted up
her skirt
now i'm going to tell you something for
sure
i have never felt creepier
than having a boner in a clown outfit
i was like i should go directly to jail
right [ __ ] now do not pass go and by
the way those pants are not made for
boners like you're not hiding uh you're
not hiding anything you know
and if i get up to the stairs let me get
into the room and i start to take the
clown stuff off she goes no leave it on
i like it on
and i was like okay
at 22 i'm not prepared for this kind of
freakiness at all but i'm like okay and
and i start to touch her she goes no i
don't want you to touch me and i was
like
she goes i'm just gonna go down on you
i'll go okay
here's my problem guys
i
tend to ruin situations
because i always go for the laugh
and so this the clown before me
had been to the first four parties
he was just out of town so i got the
call
right and the reason he got the first
four parties is because you know
she was messing around with this dude
but i can't help but
but try to go for the laugh
so
she goes down on me
and right
when i orgasmed i blew my horn home
and i just screamed that was fun like
that right
i didn't go to the next clown party i
was not invited
i'm living liquor just to make it
through another 24.
[Music]
day another foreign howler 7 p.m what's
it going to break another bug